[Music]
[Music]
so a giant sentient tree tells you that
you're not ready for the true power of
the Master Sword that you're a little
weakling a weak link so what are you
gonna do you're gonna step up and smash
the 45 floors of the Master Sword trials
like the hero you are and these hints
are going to help you do it if you've
been saving up core exceeds your best
potions and your tastiest foods now is
the time to use them you're going to
need every advantage you can get through
the trials expand your inventory get
those yellow cards and extra stamina
containers chow down on the 30 minute
plus attack or defense boost to last you
through your fights so before you get
going grab some mighty bananas from
Eventide island smash three of those
together with a mighty thistle and a
dragon horn and you'll have half an hour
of super strength the only thing you'll
keep when you warp onto that first floor
are your stat boosts all those wonderful
swords you've been saving and going to
vanish so you've got to fight like a
Hercules in Hylian boxes every single
resource is precious in the Master Sword
trials to give yourself the best chance
of victory you'll have to search high
and low for every weapon chest Apple and
slither of hope that you can find use
your bombs to crack open wooden boxes
and barrels for extra food climb the
trees in search of eggs the mother bird
won't mind check your surroundings for
chests and extra weapons so you can toss
that branch make sure you recover that
missed arrow
you're gonna need it and speaking of
arrows leave an archer for last and
sponge up near infinite arrows with an
old shield for some extra ammo
vigilance is the name of the game here
heroes in the later levels swords and
foodstuffs will be as rare as rocking
horse poo one tool that you'll be able
to keep hold off as you're battling but
cabins and lasalle foes is your trusty
Hellion iPad the sheikah slate remote
bombs will make earlier floors way
easier you can use those bad boys to
deal with squishy enemies and save your
oh so precious weapons from breaking as
well as using it to crack open those
wooden boxes Magnus's is also great to
break open the metal boxes you'll find
around the floors and what better way to
break them open than bashing them
against of a cobbling skull unless you
have literally been in stasis then
there's no reason why you should have
this stasis ruin upgraded to version 2.0
there will often be times or a hoard of
to choose a perk ovens are chasing you
down press pause on those jerks and deal
with its friends or use it against one
of your larger foes for a few cheap hits
[Music]
you may be stuck in Square rooms
underground for the time being but that
doesn't mean you can't use the world to
advantage like on floor 3 those annoying
coochies saying everything ablaze may
just land you a free chest you can
really make the most of burning shrubs
and campfires by lighting your weapon
ablaze but if you're really hurting for
health and you can always drop some raw
ingredients into a burning bush to make
the most out of them although it is
usually better to save them for floor 7
and prepare them in a cooking pot a
roasted apple or two in your time of
need may be what saves the day and while
most of your gear is still sat in couric
forest you still have your glider so
take advantage of high platforms or
burning updrafts to deliver powerful bow
shots or AoE strikes get creative it's
you against the world kids you've got to
do everything it takes to get that sweet
sweet sword
[Music]
now this may seem like an obvious one
but if you've not yet learned the
ancient arts of enemy patterns and
dodges now's the time you may have gone
through the entire game never using this
feature which is totally fine
but that may not cut the mustard in the
master sword trials
luckily once you've saved before
embarking on your new challenge you'll
have infinite opportunity to practice
your dodging skills flip and leap during
the swing of an enemy's attack or land
that perfect parry with your shield to
slow down time and start wailing on
whatever beast was foolish enough to
step to you it may take some time to get
it down but with a little practice
you'll basically be the Hylian version
of neo never taking a hit for dishing
out the hurt so those are our tips to
get you through your master sword trials
if these helps then you can show your
appreciation by liking the video and if
you've got any tips yourself then add
them into the comment section below so
Rob handler II can finally stop sucking
and finish the damn trials for more tips
and tricks from breath of the wild and
all of its upcoming DLC make sure you
subscribe to GameSpot
[Music]